stepping out of number 11 in the shadow
of the pandemic this crisis chancellor
keane to move on after two coronavirus
budgets rishi sunak now look into the
future
but there is still plenty of risk
spiraling living costs putting the
squeeze on millions of households
fueled by a better than expected
pandemic bounce back the chancellor
arriving at the commons with a clear
message today's budget does begin the
work of preparing for a new economy
postcovid the prime minister's economy
of higher wages higher skills and rising
productivity of strong public services
vibrant communities and safer streets an
economy fit for a new age of optimism a
windfall splurged on targeted tax cuts
and more spending with some help for
those on low pay
the universal credit taper withdraw
support
as people work more hours
the rate is currently 63
so for every one pound someone earns
their universal credit is reduced by
63p us be in no doubt this is a tax on
work we are cutting it from 63 to 55
the masks worn by the pm and cabinet
collies a reminder that kovid isn't over
but a promise too that as the economy
returns to normal times so will this
chancellor's approach to tax and spend
my goal is to reduce taxes by the end of
this parliament i want taxes to be going
down not up
i want this to be a society that rewards
energy ingenuity and inventiveness
a society that rewards work
that is what we believe on this side of
the house
that
is my mission over the remainder of this
parliament
kirsten absent after a positive covert
test his shadow chancellor had just
minutes to prepare accusing the
government of waste in years
time and again today the chancellor
compared the investments that he is
making to the last decade
but who was in charge
charged in this last decade
they were
but people are getting warm wise to them
every month they feel the pinch
they're tired of the smoke and mirrors
they're tired of the bluster
of the full storms of the promises of
jam tomorrow
this was a big budget with big spending
as those better than expected economic
forecasts gave the chance for a whopping
35 billion pounds a year in additional
revenue you can see now why he feels the
economy really is moving past the covid
crisis but there's a flip side to
inflation and the cost of living is on
the rise and there is a risk that the
gap between the chancellor's optimism
and people's lived experience not just
begins to grow but begins to really
great
the pm and chancellor at a brewery to
promote alcohol duty changes cheaper
pints at the parvan spirits high in
government but years of slow growth a
very real hangover
it's likely that average people's
incomes will only be crawling up over
the next three or four or even five
years and certainly some people
particularly those whose wages don't go
up as fast as prices will be feeling uh
worse off so you know this is not a new
period of everyone feeling better off
i'm afraid it's actually more of a
continuation of a decade of really you
know feeble increases in in living
standards essentially stagnation in our
standard of living
a budget that will have quenched the
pm's thirst for spending and adds to
speculation of an early election today
this duo toast in the covid recovery
the big question is will it really last
beth rigby sky news westminster